the golden knights were in their
inaugural season and played their first
home game the week after one october the
team played a key role in helping the
city recover john treach is live at
t-mobile arena where the knights have a
special ceremony planned hey john
hey there christian it was one of the
most powerful introductions in the
history of sports the golden knights hit
the ice on their home ice for the very
first time in their history flanked by
first responders and escorted by
everyday heroes it reverberated
resiliency throughout the city and
really set the tone for a special year
and a special franchise joined right now
by team president kerry vuboltz and as
you think about that time
what is most poignant
well that that night that period
you know obviously after the day after
the tragedy was such an interesting
period of time for our organization
and everything that was happening but
once we got to the home opener
which was october 10th we knew that
that we had to be part of the healing
and so that night was really about
healing and moving forward
and still to this day
my single most proud moment in my career
not only what the
what the what the energy of the of the
event was that night but just how it
made people feel and how it made me feel
that you know what we can rebound and we
can get through this and there were a
lot of people that had a lot to do with
it
but what was really stood out for me
derek england that speech he made
that was really special
and then of course we had the 58 58
seconds
moment of silence those two in
particular really
really stood out but it was just such a
special night overall it's great to have
you four years after that and we get to
do it again tonight kings golden knights
for an exhibition but it will be
powerful to so many reporting live don
treach back to you